the Parliament looked back at genre
Yonkers five years as head of the
European Commission MEP s praised his
work on social issues and the migrant
crisis but said not enough had been done
to tackle climate change European
Parliament president David sassily said
that a possible three-month brexit
extension was still on the table after
the British Parliament voted to spend
more time scrutinizing the withdrawal
agreement more than 1 million innocent
readers have been detained in camps in
China Parliament awarded the Sakharov
Prize to Ilham tohti a human rights
defender who was sentenced to life in
prison in 2014 for his work promoting
inter-ethnic dialogue more than one
hundred and seventy-six thousand people
have been displaced as a result of
turkeys military operation in northern
Syria in October MEP s condemned the
incursion and calls for measures against
the country Parliament adopted its
position on the 2020 budget including a
plan to add more than two billion euros
towards protecting the climate
[Music]